et les
en afrique du sud une foule estimée à 80
mille personnes dont nelson mandela
participer dans un stade de soweto aux
obsèques du sceau caterina du parti
communiste d'afrique du sud chris hani
de nouveaux incidents ont fait au moins
six morts aujourd'hui dont deux blancs
brûlés vifs dans l'incendié de leur
immeuble isabelle beige clair
dans le stade de soweto ils étaient 80
milles des militants de la haine c'est
en majorité certains avaient passé la
nuit là pour être sûr de pouvoir saluer
la dépouille de crise annie le leader de
la nc assassiné le 10 avril dernier
était appelée la lance de la nation par
les noirs chef de la branche armée de la
nc et dirigeant du parti communiste
il a reçu les honneurs réservés aux
héros militaire ses anciens hommes
défilent et dans l'émotion
lors du culte et de l'hommage funèbre
dirigé par nelson mandela et
l'archevêque desmond tout où le souvenir
et la politique était mais les
revendications majeures des élections
vite
en dehors du stade les militants
gauchistes du congrès panafricain plus
radicaux que la nc ont apparemment
provoqué la police qui a eu la main
lourde à son tour et a riposté à l'aide
de chevrotine et de balles réelles bilan
huit blessés dont deux graves
autour du cimetière de boxberg à 40 km
de là la tension était à son paroxysme
également on déplore six morts ce soir
au milieu de cette panique le corps de
christ annie a été mis en terre dans le
carré catholique du cimetière depuis son
assassinat le prix humain des
affrontements interethniques s'élève
déjà à 47 morts